there is there's no such thing as cheesy
when it comes to promoting yourself
promote the out of your work you
know get yourself out there and by any
means necessary I mean don't you know be
a douchebag about it be respectful and
find out workers where your particular
brand of whatever it is you're selling
is is being sold but don't be afraid to
say how great you are at it be yeah
and I don't know the teaser word Sheamus
it's sick believe in yourself no the
work that you are bringing out to the
world matters and need something
speaking of which you have a short film
workshop coming up Saturday februari 27
yes yes Saturday 930am to buy p.m. and
that's where the Writers Guild defen-
build america out so my faction third
okay and nine to five and we've got two
amazing guests cry Costel from will
morris endeavor I got fe Browns and
Samantha ward winning producer at or
invade who is a distribution maverick I
am reclaiming the word maverick okay our
vivre is a distribution on genius and i
also have Glen Morgan from todd-ao San
deluxe who Kevin's firmly linked award
winning Oscar award-winning company and
it's going to talk about sound design
and post-production okay and there's a
hundred percent money-back guarantee
it's a hundred percent money-back
guarantee if you do not walk out of that
room smarter and more prepared to make
your film then you walked in i'll give
your money back absolutely okay and
where can they find out more about it is
our website yeah then go to my website
Roberta monroe calm and they can also
good at how not to make a short film
calm very nice okay februari my seventh
930am